THE ONLY WAY TO GET TO THE TRUTH
AS ALWAYS IS TO KEEP ASKING
QUESTIONS NO MATTER WHAT THEY
SAY.
AND WE WILL DO THAT AGAIN RIGHT
NOW.
GLEAMING YOUNG IS THE VIROLOGIST
SAYS SHE HAS EVIDENCE ABOUT
WHERE THIS PANDEMIC EVER CAME
FROM.
DOCTOR, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
>> Tucker: I KNOW YOU ARE
PUBLISHING MORE RESEARCH SOON.
GIVE US A SUMMARY OF WHY YOU
BELIEVE THIS VIRUS CAME FROM A
LAB IN WUHAN?
>> BRIEFLY FROM A FIRST REPORT,
THIS VIRUS -- ACTUALLY IS NOT
FROM NATURE.
IT IS A MAN-MADE VIRUS CREATED
IN THE LAB BASED ON THE VERY
UNIQUE BAT CORONAVIRUS WHICH
CANNOT AFFECT PEOPLE BUT AFTER
THE MODIFICATIONS BECOMES A VERY
HARMFUL VIRUS.
SO I HAVE EVIDENCE TO SHOW WHY
THEY CAN DO IT.
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE, HOW DID
THEY DO IT.
>> Tucker: IT’S WHAT YOU’RE
SAYING IS MUCH MORE SINISTER
EVEN THEN WHAT WE HAVE SUGGESTED
ON THE SHOW.
YOU ARE SAYING THAT THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT MANUFACTURED THIS
VIRUS, IF I’M HEARING YOU
CORRECTLY?
IS THAT WHEN YOU ARE SAYING?
>> YES EXACTLY.
BASED ON THE VIRUS GENOME, IT’S
BASICALLY LIKE OUR FINGERPRINT
SO YOU CAN SEE THE VERY UNUSUAL
CHARACTERS IN THEIR GENOME.
WHICH COULD BE BASED ON T THE
OTHER EVIDENCE, WE CAN FINALLY
SEE THAT COME FROM THEIR OWN
SPECIAL CORONAVIRUS.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU ARE
ALLEGING IS SHOCKING EVEN MORE
THAN I ANTICIPATED WHEN WE
INVITED YOU ON.
SO I WANT TO ASK THE MOST
OBVIOUS QUESTION WHICH IS THIS
GENOME THAT PRESUMABLY IS IN
POSSESSION OF MANY RESEARCHERS
AROUND THE WORLD, WHY IS NOBODY
SAYING THIS IF IT’S TRUE?
>> IT’S BECAUSE OF THE BIG
SUPPRESSION COMING FROM THE
CHINESE COMMUNITY, THE
GOVERNMENT AND ALSO THEIR
FRIENDS IN THE SCIENTIFIC WORLD.
SO BASICALLY THIS IS VERY CLEAR,
AND THOSE THINGS, LIKE BASICALLY
A COW, DEAR HAVE AND RABBITS
HERE AND MONKEYS.
SO THEY CAN NEVER GET IT FROM
THE NATURE.
THAT’S THE LAST IN THE GENOME.
THE SCIENTIFIC -- ALSO WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
THEY DON’T WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
THE TRUTH.
ALSO, THAT’S WHY I GOT SUSPENDED
SUSPENDED, I GOT -- THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY WON’T BE FEARED.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE A BRAVE
PERSON AND I’M GIVING YOU THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
IT’S NOT LIKE TWITTER WOULD SHUT
YOU DOWN OR WHY YOU ARE BEING
IGNORED.
WHY WOULD THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT
INTENTIONALLY CREATE A VIRUS
LIKE THIS?
>> IF YOU WANT TO KNOW THE EXACT
MOTIVE, THE EXACT IDEA, ASKED
THE COMMUNIST PARTY WHY THEY DO
THE ETA BECAUSE THEY ARE THE
ONES WHO DO A DAY.
WE CANNOT ALWAYS UNDERSTAND
THEIR EVIL THINKING.
YOU HAVE TO COME TO ASK THEM.
BUT WHAT WE SEE ALREADY PROVES
THAT THEY HAVE FOUND THAT,
EVERYONE IN THE WORLD LEADS TO
THE HISTORIC PANDEMIC AND
INVOLVES EVERYONE.
>> Tucker: HOW DO YOU BELIEVE
THIS VIRUS MADE ITS WAY FROM THE
LAB IN WUHAN TO THE REST OF THE
WORLD?
>> FIRST, I HAVE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE AND ALSO MY NEXT REPORT
WILL COME OUT SOON.
THE OTHER THING IS, I WORK IN
THE W.H.O. REFERENCE LAB WHICH
IS THE TOP VIRUS LAB IN THE
WORLD TO COME AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF HONG KONG.
I GET INVESTIGATION FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING OF THIS OUTBREAK,
I HAVE MY INTELLIGENCE BECAUSE I
ALSO GET MY OWN UNIQUE NETWORK
IN CHINA WITH THE HOSPITAL AND
ALSO -- I WORK WITH THAT TYPE
TOP CORONAVIRUS VIROLOGIST IN
THE WORLD.
THIS IS FROM THE TEMPLATE OWNED
BY CHINA, AND ALSO IT HAS SPREAD
TO THE WORLD TO MAKE SUCH
DAMAGE.
>> Tucker: DO YOU BELIEVE THAT
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT TO
RELEASE THIS INTENTIONALLY, ON
PURPOSE?
DID THEY DO THIS?
>> YES, IT’S INTENTIONALLY.
EVEN THOUGH THERE IS MORE
EVIDENCE YOU CAN ALREADY SEE
WHAT THEY HAVE TRIED TO COVER UP
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING AS I
REVIEWED IN DIFFERENT MEDIA
BEFORE, AND ALSO WHAT ELSE THEY
HAVE DONE, LIKE MAKING THE
FABRICATED VIRUS, CENSORSHIP,
AND ALSO TRYING TO MAKE PEOPLE
LIKE ME TALK ABOUT THE TRUTH GET
DISAPPEARED.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW, IT’S HARD
TO BE SHOCKED IN A MOMENT LIKE
THIS BUT YOU HAVE SUCCEEDED IN
SHOCKING ME.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS NOT THE
FORM FOR THE DETAILS OF YOUR
RESEARCH, I DON’T HAVE THE
GROUNDING TO ASK YOU THE RIGHT
QUESTION BUT THIS IS WHERE YOU
WISH FOR A FUNCTIONING MEDIA
BECAUSE WHAT YOU JUST SAID TO
COMPLETELY CHANGES EVERYTHING WE
THINK WE KNOW ABOUT THE PANDEMIC
THAT IS WRECKING OUR COUNTRY.
I HOPE SINCERELY THAT THERE WILL
BE MANY DIFFERENT INTERVIEWS FOR
THE MEDIA AND EXPLAIN THIS.